[Music]
as i'm sure you've noticed
prices are rising faster in america than
at any time since the financial crisis
in 2008.
a recent harris poll survey for usa
today found that 83 percent of
sorry 83 percent of americans are
concerned about it and that's of course
bound to have an effect on how people
shop we are joined now by usa
today's economic opportunity reporter i
love that title
charisse jones cherise good morning good
morning hi
well quickly what is an economic
opportunity reporter and then what is
going on with these prices
yeah well i write about racial equity
and what you need to do economically to
get people to be able to bridge the
wealth gap that exists between different
racial groups so
it's a really important thing to talk
about right now and the prices are
really impacting people because
a lot of folks don't have enough money
and everything is up across the board
from clothing to groceries to cars
and why what's going on well it's a lot
of things i mean the pandemic really
upended
everything right so supply lines got
really clogged you couldn't get people
to ports and to factories
to kind of produce these things so it's
costing a lot more to ferry
the merchandise the materials and the
items so companies and brands are
charging more
are getting charged more and they're
passing that on to consumers who are
seeing that at the grocery store in the
shopping mall so what do you do i mean
first of all how long do you think this
supply jam is going to last because i
was looking for a sofa earlier this week
and they said
december you know of this year yes wow
that'll be a christmas present furniture
makers are paying like 30
more for lumber which is what you need
for sofas and shares and so a lot of
economists are saying
they think that it's going to kind of
slip in the next few months
you know as the pandemic eases and
people start you know the demand goes
down a little bit
and the flow starts again but you never
know you never know what forces are
going to act up
and do you think that's where the
biggest change in prices might come or
we may get some
a little bit of relief yeah because a
lot of it is this log jam
right and there's also a lot of pent up
demand i mean people couldn't go
anywhere they couldn't buy a lot of
things
they weren't flying and so when you get
that out of your system then the prices
start
to slip a little bit but we don't know
when that's going to happen exactly
we hope in the next few months do you
think that there are certain things you
should buy in bulk i always think toilet
paper is one because we're all going to
need it i don't care what color you are
how much money you have
everybody's going to need toilet paper
yeah yeah so do you think items like
that it's okay to buy in bulk but they
were even rationing that for a time
yeah i think that buying in bulk is a
good idea if you have some place to put
it
and if you're going to use it right so
if you buy a lot of fruit if you have a
big family three kids or four kids
and you're going to go through it that's
a good idea you know we learned during
the pandemic we really needed toilet
paper and hand sanitizer
but you've got to have a place to store
it i mean you don't want to have the big
jar of tomato sauce
you take the lid off and there's mold on
the top yeah because you haven't used it
so you know make sure you're going to
use it you have some places to put all
that stuff
i feel that about avocados
i buy avocados and then most of the time
they just sit there and go bad after
somebody needs to think about it you got
it or something
when you go to the store and you buy
something you're used to those raisinets
or the potato chips
and there's less in the bag or in the
box or the package
but the price is the same or it's more
and the reason that companies get away
with this is that we're very sensitive
to price
you notice when the orange juice costs a
dollar more but you don't notice when
the carton's a little bit lighter
so it's a way for them to make a little
bit more money you know boost their
profits and you don't know that you're
getting ripped off a little bit and
nothing we can do just
except being ripped off well you know
you can like you know
make notes i mean look at the the weight
of the product look at the price and
then compare it
and if you go back next time and it is a
little bit lighter a little bit more
expensive
you can go to a rival brand and see what
they're offering store brands tend to be
cheaper
and they tend to be the last brands that
play that game with the volume
so that's often a good bet too and
that's happening now the volume of
products is going down in the packaging
yeah it tends to go with inflation so
when prices go up companies are looking
at
lots of tricks to get more money and to
boost their profits and so a lot of
things
cereal and snack goods and paper
products people are noticing that
they're not getting as much bang for
their buck yeah so when you pick up the
peanut butter jar and it
feels a little smaller it's not all in
your imagination it's not
or the different towel with razor nets
definitely truth raising that's that box
is like that and you open up
it's it's like that high right do you
have any tips on how people can save
money during this time
you know coupons are always i mean
they've been around for generations
right but they still
no work your app now you can get them on
your computer website
i mean again store brands are always a
good way to go look at alternate store
chains like aldi
all these exploding right and a lot of
their products produce and dairy might
be cheaper than walmart
and some of the better known chains and
you know really mark your calendar about
every six
weeks things go on sale at the grocery
store
and so if you have a discount at this
time and roughly a month you might be
able to get a similar discount on a
similar item charisse jones
great advice thank you so much for being
with us this morning